warning for those of you who haven't
seen episode 8 of The Last of Us there
will be spoilers all I ask is 10 seconds
of your time one of my favorite segments
from The Last of Us Part One is David
and the cannibals not only is it
action-packed but navigating this
absolutely psychotic flesh eater
storyline has one of the most brutal
payoffs in the entire game so when the
latest episode of The Last of Us came
out I was more excited than Hannibal
Lecter at an open Buffet but as I got
deeper into the added lore creators Neil
druckman and Craig Mason added to the
show I started to piece together what
might be one of the show's most shocking
moments this is something that's heavily
implied yet and never mentioned it
involves one character unknowingly
eating her own father follow me as we
look at all the clues and you can make a
judgment for yourself if episode 8 is
hiding this truly unimaginable horror
unlike the game the show allows us to
meet the townspeople of Silver Lake
Colorado a once bustling ski resort now
home to a famish group of Christian
Believers the winter months have been
especially hard and as James tells us
food has been dwindling in order to
survive David the group's Pastor leader
has made the difficult decision to
supplement their meals with human flesh
but not all the town folk know this
disturbing fact as we get further into
the episode we get a sense of who knows
about the interesting dietary addition
to their meals James David's right-hand
man surely knows as well as Josiah who
to appears was responsible for chopping
up these chunks of meat a piece of which
Ellie finds on the floor of her cell the
next day so clue number one is that the
ear Ellie finds on the ground here was
likely Left Behind from the meal the
night before the meal we see everyone
including this girl Hannah here enjoying
now one of the episodes of biggest
reveals is that the man Joel killed at
the end of episode 6 was one of David's
men his name was Alec and he left behind
a wife Joyce and daughter Hannah we know
that his body was brought back to Silver
Lake as Hannah asked when they can bury
him and here's clue number two when she
asked this Quest question take a look at
the Quick Glance he gives over to James
it's kind of like a uh oh what do we say
here him and James both know that body
ain't ever gonna be buried that's some
prime meat that could be used to sustain
their people who are already on the
verge of death now clue 3 when it comes
to the actual preparation of the meat
Joyce asks what it is and just take a
look at how Shifty Josiah's eyes are
here as he lies and says it's venison in
fact this leads me to the fourth clue we
actually never see any wild game like
venison elk rabbit anywhere on the
Silver Lake Compound when Joel uncovers
their makeshift Meat Locker there's only
Ellie's horse and three hanging bodies
we don't see anything else so when David
asked James at the beginning of the
episode how much deer elk and rabbit
they have left I think it's all code for
human meat another interesting point is
their prayer that they say during dinner
which refers to their meal as the quote
Living bread a reference to the act of
communion which a piece of bread
symbolizes the body of Christ but in
this context they are literally eating
human flesh as the meal is consumed
there are once again some suspicious
glances between our characters take a
look at James here as one of a few
people who isn't voraciously eating away
he's taking these tiny bites likely
because he's looking over at Hannah who
just ate her own father unfortunately
the game doesn't offer much insight into
this matter since characters like Hannah
and Alec never appear in the game so
it's up to us to use these Clues and
make up our own minds as to what
actually happened this is where I turn
it over to you did Hannah actually eat
her father could it have been another
person or was our trustworthy Josiah
telling the truth when he said it was
indeed venison I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching everyone if
you haven't checked out my episode 8
breakdown make sure to do that and
please like And subscribe for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember if you want to judge me
[Music]